stranded and Afraid a teenager pleads
for her mother mom please she says look
at me now she was one of the survivors
found by Rescuers on Mount marapi after
the volcano erupted on Sunday many of
them are University students who are
hiking up the 2,900 M Mountain
authorities say their search efforts
have been hampered by ongoing volcanic
activity and heavy
rain main obstacle is there have been
several eruptions and volcanic ash fell
all the way to the foot of the mountain
this man is waiting for news of his
son my son was hiking in a group of 18
people but they separated into two
groups until now they still haven't
found them survivors have been taken to
hospital many have severe burns and
broken limbs Zan's daughter has burns on
her face arms legs and hands she was
also wounded by Falling
Rocks five of the hikers were near the
crater when it erupted they were
scattered around my daughter rolled down
the slopes finally the search team
carried her
down local authorities say Ash and rocks
fell on several districts near the
volcano and they are urging those living
close to the mountain to stay indoors to
protect themselves from respiratory
infections Jessica Washington Al jaaz
Jakarta make sure to subscribe to our
Channel channel to get the latest news
from Al
jaaz